d'abord cinéma avec la sortie de main du
nouveau film de jacques audiard sur mes
lèvres vincent cassel joue un voyou à
peine sorti de prison dont le chemin
croise celui d'une secrétaire complexé
emmanuelle devos récit pascal deschamps
bernard puceau
wikus est fleuri j'étais centrale
contrat le toit
enfin des particuliers sur mes lèvres
c'est un peu du rififi chez les paumés
tantôt lost my own ou voilà elle carla
se faire mal entendantes exploiter et
frustré lui paul ex taulard futur rien
du tout leur rencontre provoquée par
l'anpe
ce n'est pas vraiment celle de ray de
votre leurre et scarlett o'hara joly sur
leurs lèvres alors là par exemple
je me suis pas mal débrouillé c'est une
chance pour un cadeau comme moi d'avoir
entre la sourde futé et le mauvais
garçon habile de ses mains une étonnante
complicité va naître comme si les gnons
de la ville où propre comme au figuré
les avait rapprochés au contact l'un de
l'autre ils font des étincelles ils sont
capables de faire des choses qu'il
n'aurait même pas imaginer faire je
crois donc qu'il ya un espèce de côté
tout d'un coup ils font leur vie devient
extraordinaire parce qu'ils sont
ensemble des gens dangereux pour lui le
si par hasard
de réaliste parce que sociale le film
devient suis lèvres l'intriguent ce
temps l'estomac se serre la caméra
d'audiard ne lâche pas ses héros d'une
semaine mouvement et lumière 6l une
atmosphère alors que j'arrive à leers
qui se dit le pape
mais si loin sans doute et je dois le
savoir soit être capable de lire d'ici
ok j'ai vraiment la sensation de
m'amuser avec avec emmanuel jacques à
être très précis et on s'amuse avec des
orfèvres mais on s'amuse quand même
beaucoup
un plaisir partagé par le spectateur sur
mes lèvres et ados son film noir comme
on n'en fait plus un film sensuel qui
vont contribuer si vous pouviez lire sur
mes lèvres vous désiriez qu'aux bonnes
choses et puis cette image au japon